- Yes! Battle Royale for championship! Where we dropping, boys?
- Same as always, the highest point on the map?
- Yes! The ideal location to be good at home but never win conference!
To mountain!
- Go Cow Town! Oh, yeah, a legendary chest!
We’re finally gonna get the Kings’ first Victory Royale!
Nope.
Just gray guns, and a note from Vlade saying he traded away all the good stuff.
What did the Lakers get?
- Purple and gold.
- We’ve got a sweet loadout here.
- Yeah, but for once, we’ve got to cut the crap and play together.
Hey, where’s Ben?
- Over here, mate!
I'm a bush!
- Please get out of the bush, Ben.
- No. It’s perfect camouflage!
I’m 50 percent point guard, 50 percent power forward, 100 percent bush.
- Dammit, Ben. No one wants to play with a bush camper.
Right, Joel?
Joel?
- He’s in the bush with me now!
- Come on in, Al. If you wanna be part of The Process, you gotta be part of the bush.
- Where the heck is Harden?! I swear, all he cares about is getting the latest skins.
- Check it out! Hottest skin in the game!
- Private Westbrook reporting for duty. With a knockwurst pickaxe!
- I gotta have a word with my guy at the item shop.
- ¡Qué suerte! Things are looking good!
The storm is closing in, and Giannis will never make it.
- I don’t know, I heard he can Eurostep the entire island.
- That’s impossible! No one can--
- Only three steps. Not a travel!
This should’ve been mine.
- Well, Kawhi, I guess there’s only two teams left in the battle for the West.
- No, there’s not!
Beef Boss! This skin isn’t even available right now.
No way Russ can beat this one.
- Check it out! Beef Boss with a dog backpack!
And the dog has a DJ horn!
- Wise investment of V-Bucks!
And don’t forget Nuggets!
- Or Milwaukee!
We control the East, and this attractive bush.
- We’ve gotta get closer, Joel. I can only shoot from within three feet.
- Whoa. What’s going on?
- I’m afraid we had a technical glitch.
Sorry, guys, but the game’s over for now. We have to reboot.
- Reboot?
So what happens now?
- We’re all going to Disney World!
- Really?
- Some of us are going to Disney World!